did she love sometimes you know I
thought it might be fun to try on like a
few iconic frames see how they look on
you are you cool with that I'm with it
all right all right come on you're gonna
go with these first these these are like
they kind of look like you to like Bono
a little bono esque so let's try these
make some noise Bono
[Applause]
okay okay well this one this is a I
think Oprah has been rocking a bold look
like these this is it so I mean if it's
good for Oprah it's good for all of us
right this is probably
you are good in sunglasses you want the
perfect shape head I'm not kidding I
have to go for a specific styler it's
like nope okay we're going to go for
these obviously these are a little Elton
John make some noise crowd John
[Applause]
if you had to pick cuz I'm just saying
the bedazzle is nice I may go with these
Oh you're going over my I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
YouTube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this